巴黎的 Primo 這家公司，他們最近募到 690 萬歐元，將推出自主 AI 代理，要幫企業的 IT 團隊把工作自動化。這聽起來很像科幻電影會出現的，但他們真的做到了。
嗯，自主 AI 代理，聽起來很厲害。但 IT 團隊的工作，真的能讓 AI 全包嗎？會不會只是噱頭，實際上還是要人去處理那些複雜的例外狀況？
其實這就是他們厲害的地方。Primo 創辦人 Martin Pannier 在 2022 年就開始做這件事。他們蓋了一個平台，把公司所有的裝置、SaaS 應用、員工資料跟 IT 支援全部整合起來。
把所有資料都整合，這點不稀奇。很多公司也試圖這麼做，但往往資料散落在各個系統，很難統一。Primo 怎麼解決這個問題？
他們的 AI 代理不是一般的 AI 助理，不只回答問題或給建議。Headline 的合夥人 Jonathan Userovici 提到，Primo 有一個結構性優勢，就是他們的平台已經整合了所有情境、所有資料，還有執行 IT 操作所需的規則。
等等，這裡我有疑問。你說的「結構性優勢」具體是什麼？光是整合資料還不夠，重點是要能「執行」動作，而且要準確無誤。
沒錯，這就是關鍵。Primo 的 AI 代理能直接「執行」工作。例如，當新員工加入，AI 代理會在 HR 系統偵測到這個事件，然後它會自動訂購硬體、預設電腦、根據職位分配 SaaS 存取權限，甚至開立一個歡迎工單。
喔，這個做法很有意思。聽起來是把整個入職流程完全自動化了。那離職呢？
離職也是一樣。當員工離開公司，AI 代理會反向操作，立刻撤銷所有敏感的存取權限。想像一下，所有這些重複性高、容易出錯的工作都由 AI 來做，IT 團隊就能把時間花在更重要的事情上。
如果這麼說，那它確實解決了 IT 團隊的痛點。IT 職位薪水不低，光是處理這些例行公事，對企業來說就是一筆不小的成本。這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字。
是啊，原文有說他們已經簽了超過 400 個客戶，涵蓋新創公司、快速成長型企業，還有員工數在 50 到 2000 人的中小企業，橫跨十個國家。他們的年經常性收入已經超過 340 萬歐元，而且營收年年成長四倍。
營收成長四倍，這數字確實不錯。這說明市場對這種「自主 AI 代理」的需求是真的存在。那如果我們是中小企業主，可以從中學到什麼？
我覺得最關鍵的啟發是，不要只把 AI 當成一個工具，而是要把它設計成能自主運作的「代理人」。就像 Primo 這樣，把 AI 深度整合到企業的核心流程裡，讓它能獨立完成一整套任務。
嗯，這確實是與一般想法不同的。我們常常把 AI 想成是輔助工具，而不是決策與執行的主體。
對，想想看，如果把客服、財務報銷、倉儲管理這些高成本、重複性高的流程，也都交給這種自主 AI 代理來處理，營運成本能大幅降低，效率也會提升很多。
那一般上班族呢？這個概念可以怎麼帶入自己的工作或生活？
其實我們也可以思考，自己日常工作中，有沒有哪些重複性高、規則明確的任務？像是定期整理文件、發送週報、排程會議等等。如果能找到一些工具，將這些流程串起來，讓它像 AI 代理一樣自動跑，也能省下不少時間。
說起來，這好像也提醒了我們，未來的工作可能不再只是「使用」工具，而是要學會「設計」工具，甚至讓工具自主運作。